you just I'm told completed a triathlon
which I think makes you the best athlete
sitting here tonight
did you just did a triathlon I've never
done a triathlon yeah it was fun it's
very hot I was the third year I've done
it was the Malibu triathlon for
Children's Hospital good calm and yes
children should stay well guys it's
really hot this year but we were talking
earlier and we were talking about uh you
know the first year I did it they have
these Trent you get these transition
times where we transitioned from the
swim to the bike and the first year I I
did it I didn't understand these things
and they give you like all these babies
come you know is biking costumes and
everything and Fox gives you like this
biking shirt and I remember throwing on
like the Fox biking shirt and sitting up
and being like oh well this is far too
tight I look ridiculous in this and like
taking it off and then there I spent
like eight minutes in the transition
area like picking out an outfit does
that count toward you that counts
towards your time right that's a hundred
percent my dad my dad looked at the
times afterwards I was like what were
you doing in the transition area I was
like I was picking out an outfit dad I
don't understand the concept of what was
going I just picture you looking in a
rack like
[Music]
we were discussing because it's like you
know you you people take photos of you
are you doing this triathlon and looking
at photos of yourself as you're working
out you know you you one might think
that you maybe you look like Blake
Griffin when you're working it's exactly
the exact opposite unfortunately it
doesn't it they always get an awkward it
just looks awkward since you're in there
and you're doing it and you're like
running and you're perspiring you're
just sweating you're like yeah this
suppose mailing is I'm gonna get for
them for the year yeah and then you see
a photograph of it I think we have a
photo of you of you in the triathlon
yeah it's like you just realized you
have armpit hair it's like you just
finished Marley & Me only like you have
to go to the bathroom but they say now
it's just you I had to ask you about
this there's a your show obviously very
popular new girl there's a fake drinking
game on the show that you get completely
invented it's made up called true
American and it's almost impossible to
do I mean it doesn't really exist
there are people who do what they send
with pictures on Twitter what I'm
hearing is that you're now getting
photos from people saying we've played
the game
yeah the photos simply look like binge
drinking with pillows which is where
being with drinking always ends I'm not
sure the safest thing in the world but
we've definitely started a trend to some
degree and it's a game that has no mean
because on the show it's meant it sounds
like it involves presidential trivia and
lava and you can't stand on the floor
and oh you've seen it before yeah I have
yeah it's yeah it involves all those
things I'm not quite sure exactly what
the parameters are but it exists and
people have kind of taken all those
things that you mentioned and kind of
created their own rules to then create
this game true American that was
invented on our show and we don't
necessarily know how to play
as long as you can monetize it and own
it right that's all that's important
yeah he should say yeah it's gonna take
off
you